Hey everybody, Ryan here and welcome back to our oral surgery series.
This video will be about implants and implant surgery.
And this is a vast topic that could involve an enormous series just by itself.
So this will just be a cursory look at implants and implant surgery, focusing again on the
high yield topics for the board exam, and also for your own edification.
So why do we place implants, of course, to replace a missing tooth?
Here is a really nice schematic showing an implant being placed into bone, and here is
a radiograph of the finished result with a restored implant crown.
Here are indications for placing an implant, we have a list here, uncontrolled diabetes
and immunocompromised patients.
These are both at higher risk of infection.
The volume and height of bone needs to be sufficient in order to support an implant.
Bizphosphinate therapy, that patient will be at risk of Bizphosphinate related osteonacrosis
of the jaws or branch.
And you may be noticing that a lot of these are contraindications for tooth extraction
as well, and there's quite a bit of overlap between these two lists.
Bruxism, a patient who is constantly clenching and grinding their teeth, may not be the best
fit for an implant.
Smoking is a relative contraindication, again all of these are relative contraindications.
A history of head and neck radiation, another familiar site from the tooth extraction, contraindication
list, a patient with cleft palate, and adolescents.
Adolescents are not done growing, so if we place an implant in one part of the bone,
as they continue to grow and their jaws continue to grow, that implant may not be in the place
that we want it to be.
So we need to wait until 2022-24, until that bone is completely done growing and we don't
have to worry about that implant moving around.
Now along with age, old age is not a contraindication for placing an implant.
Just because you're older doesn't mean you can't have an implant and can't have a really
nice result with an implant.
So you may get a board's question that poses the scenario where you have an older patient,
and that alone is not a contraindication for receiving an implant.
All of these are relative contraindications.
So we have three main categories of implants.
These are big picture categories.
Sub-periosteal, and if we unpack this name, that means under the periosteum, and it literally
rests under the periosteum layer.
And so it's not screwed into the bone at all, it's laying underneath the periosteum just
like a blanket.
And this metal framework has extensions that poke through the oral mucosa shown in pink
here for retention of a prosthesis.
So there's no true osteointegration with this implant, and we'll talk about osteointegration
later in the video, and therefore has a very poor prognosis.
So it's rare to see these around at all today, and that's because most of them, if they were
placed a while ago, have since failed, and they're not a great option for implant therapy.
Next we have trans-austeal, or trans-austeous.
Either way you write it, that can be, that can refer to trans-meaning through and osteo-meaning
the bone.
So these implants are placed through the bone.
Now these are exclusive to the mandibular anterior region because it requires an extra-oral approach.
You drill this one through the inferior border of the mandible and into the oral mucosa.
Usually they involve two to four trans-mandibular implants in order to support a larger framework.
Again, these are very rare, it's a very involved surgery, and do not have great success either.
So that leaves us with the third category, endosteal or endosseous.
We unpack this word, it means "into" or "in" the bone.
And so the endosteal implants are placed into the bone.
Now these are available in many different forms, there's a blade shape, a rainness frame,
and the ones that are depicted here that we see by far most often.
And what we'll talk about throughout this video is the root form implant.
It's generally cylindrical, and it's called a root form implant because it's shaped like
a tooth root.
And so let's talk about the endosteal implant.
So an endosteal implant has four primary components, if we boil it down.
And from bottom to top in the schematic, we have the implant body, the abutment, the abutment
screw, and the implant crown.
So now in the next couple slides, let's unpack each of these components.
So the implant body, also called just the implant or the implant fixture, is shown here in
the top right.
It's usually axis symmetric, which means if I were to draw a long axis down the center
of this implant, it would be symmetric around that long axis.
The basic procedure for placing an implant such as this one is to drill a hole into the
bone.
And we sequentially enlarge that osteotomy, which is a fancy name for the bone hole.
So we start with a smaller drill, much smaller than the diameter of this implant, then we
go to a larger one, a larger one, and finally one that's large enough to create a hole that
will support this implant being drilled into it.
So the reason why we sequentially enlarge the osteotomy is to, number one, reduce the
amount of heat generated.
And this helps to keep the bone cells alive, which we desperately want, and having a sharp
drill, and also using copious irrigation, helps with reducing heat generated as well.
Secondly, it helps to maintain the axis with freehand surgery.
So what the heck does that mean?
Well when we're doing an implant placement, we can be using a stent or a template of sorts,
and we'll talk about that a little bit later, or you can be placing the implant freehanded.
Now of course you have radiographs, or better yet, a cone beam CT image, basically a three
dimensional x-ray, so you know how wide the bone is, how deep the bone is, and you know
what angulation a place that implant at, but being able to check the hole at each step,
you can check how you're doing with your angulation.
So you start with a really small hole, you put in a little indicator, and you can say,
well, my hole's a little bit too angled distally, so next time when I go up to the next bigger
drill, I can correct that angulation.
So it gives you some opportunities to correct and maintain a proper axis.
The implant body is usually inserted into tapped holes, and a tapped hole in carpentry,
or any trade for that matter, is a hole drilled prior to a screw being inserted.
It's similar to a pilot hole, except that it has the threads cut into the inside surface
of the hole.
However, some of these implants are self-tapping, and you can see that by these little gouges
that are made in the apical part of the implant, and so they essentially cut and create their
own threads as they're drilled into the bone hole, and thus do not require this step.
So that's some big picture information about the implant body.
Now let's talk about the abutment.
So the abutment is the part of the implant schematic here that is placed onto you and
into the implant body.
So the abutment can be broken down into two big categories, one piece abutments and two
piece abutments.
So let's spend some time digging into the differences between these two categories.
So the one piece abutment combines the abutment and the abutment screw into one component.
So if we go back to the schematic, that's combining the abutment and the abutment screw
into one big piece.
So the screw is actually a part of the abutment, and so the whole thing screws into the inside
of the implant body, and this beautiful cross section image here shows that abutment adapting
to the inside of the implant body, and then that screw holding it in place.
So here is the implant body, the abutment screw, which is part of the larger abutment.
It has no anti-rotation component, which we'll talk about in a later slide.
Notice it has a smooth conical shape, which is called a conus, C-O-N-U-S, that wedges into
the top of the implant to ensure proper seating.
Now more commonly used is the two piece abutment, and so the abutment is held to the implant
body via a screw that goes down the center of both.
So in the two piece abutment, the abutment screw and the abutment are separate components.
And so in the cross section image here, you can see the outside of the abutment, which
is here and here, interfaces with the implant body, which is this part here, and this part
here, and the screw, the abutment screw, that drills down the center of both the abutment
and the implant body.
And this is a bit difficult to comprehend, but if we break it down into the four major
components of an implant, hopefully that can make it a little bit easier.
So this abutment does have an anti-rotation component, because you can seat it and lock
it in place, and then place the abutment screw through that whole assembly.
And again, we'll talk more about the anti-rotation component a little bit later, and why that
makes the two piece abutment a little bit more desirable than the one piece in most cases.
And finally, let's talk about the implant crown.
So the implant crown itself can be broken down into two categories, the screw-retained
crown, and a cement-retained crown.
So for the screw-retained crown, we would place a screw through the crown into the implant,
and in general, the abutment and crown of this type are fabricated as one component.
And then the abutment screw is placed through the entire piece into the implant.
So this is technically a, now we're combining the crown and the abutment components, and
then the abutment screw shown in gold here is drilled through both of them.
So this is technically would be an example of a two piece abutment, where the screw and
abutment are separate.
Now the cons of this type are that we have a screw access hole, and so the screw access
hole is typically placed in the central fossa, in the posterior teeth, or in the singular
area of the anterior teeth.
Now the screw and the access hole is very apparent, and could create an aesthetic problem.
And what we typically would do is place some Teflon tape into the hole, and then place
a composite plug to fill in the rest of the hole.
So you need to position the access hole in a non-aesthetic area to avoid, even though
you can match the color somewhat with composite, you usually want to leave it a little bit,
a little bit distinguishable from the implant crown in case you had to go back and access
that screw at a later time.
Obviously, this screw access hole can't be coming through the facial surface of an incisor.
So this is why the implant has to be planned thoroughly ahead of time to ensure proper
placement and angulation of the implant, so that the crown and this screw access hole
can be angled in a proper direction.
So now the pros of this screw retain crown, one of them I already mentioned, is that it
can be removed at a later time.
All you have to do is take out the composite plug, take out the Teflon tape, and then you
can take the screw out, remove the screw, and take the crown off, clean the components,
and do other things that are beneficial.
You have no cement to worry about with this screw retain crown, which is a benefit.
We'll talk more about that in just a little bit.
And the big one is that it takes up less vertical restorative space than the cement retained,
so it's better for restricted restorative space areas.
Now the cement retained crown is where the abutment is attached as a separate component
from the crown, so these two are now separate, and you can have either the one piece abutment
with its own screw, or the two piece abutment with a separate screw.
So like I say here, the abutment is attached separately to the implant.
The pros for this one are that there's no screw access hole, so it's typically better
for anterior teeth and incisors, because now we don't have to worry about having a screw
access hole in an aesthetic area that could compromise our final result.
The big con is, well I guess there are two of them.
Once it's cemented, it can't be removed unless it's physically cut off, and the one I have
listed here, which is probably most frequently tested, is that cement may be trapped subgingivally.
And so if it's trapped under the gingiva, it can cause peri implantitis.
To remember that's essentially peridontal disease around an implant instead of around
a tooth.
So you have the same symptoms.
You have gingiva inflammation and bone loss, and this is a big, big problem.
And cement, a lot of research shows that cement can be a big cause of this.
So that's a big negative, and typically why it's considered standard of care after placing
a any implant, but particularly for cement retained implants, to take a periapical radiograph
or a bite wing and so you can see if there's cement that was left over and not cleaned
out after placement.
All right, so those were the four components of implants.
Now let's talk about one piece versus two piece implants.
So the one piece implant, this is not to be confused with the one and two piece abutments,
the one piece implant is where the implant body and the abutment are physically attached
together.
And so this whole component, now we don't even have an abutment screw, we just have the
abutment and the implant combined together and they're drilled into bone as one unit.
One way to, one helpful way to view the abutment component is as the quote unquote crown prep
of this metal tooth.
And it's like the metal crown prep that the implant crown will sit onto.
And the problem with a one piece implant is that you cannot correct the angle between
the two components because they're attached as one piece, whereas once an implant's placed
and maybe you want to correct for an angulation error, you can purchase an abutment that has
a certain angle built into it and so you can correct that post implant surgery.
The two piece implant is much more common and the implant and the final abutment are
a separate components.
And so the final abutment and the crown are typically placed at the same appointment.
Probably several weeks after the implant has been placed to allow the bone to heal and
osteointegrate, which again we'll talk about a little bit later.
And so once the abutment is in place, the crown can either be cemented on top, which
is the cement retained or the crown, which includes the abutment are screwed together
into the implant, which is the screw retained crown.
All right, let's talk about that anti-rotation component that I mentioned before.
And so the anti-rotation component can take several different forms.
Here we see an internal hex, which is this is the top of the implant body and it has
this index that's built into the inside of the implant so that when you place an abutment,
it can only go in a certain amount of ways, it locks in like a lock and key so that once
the abutment is fully seated, it can't spin around and rotate and rock back and forth.
Here's an external hex, which shows a similar index, but this time this hexagon is going
to lock into the abutment in this direction, this way the abutment is going to lock down
into the implant body.
So both of these are providing the same objective to prevent rotation of the abutment and to
provide stabilization of the abutment.
So essentially it's preventing spinning and preventing rocking back and forth of the abutment
and spinning and rocking are very undesirable outcomes.
So having this index to lock the various components together helps tremendously.
And again, just to recapitulate this, the anti-rotation component can only be involved
with the two piece abutments because the one piece abutment has to screw down as a conical,
a uniformly conical shape, so it can afford to have this kind of locking hex mechanism.
Alright this is another thing that I mentioned before and it's another great topic to talk
about and this is the topic of integration.
So osteo integration is a very desirable feature of titanium implants.
The great thing about titanium and a bit more recently zirconium is its biocompatibility
and the ability to osteo integrate with bone.
So osteo integration refers to a direct structural and functional connection between ordered
living bone and the surface of a load bearing artificial implant.
So you usually want to check osteo integration before you place the final abutment and certainly
the final crown so that no mobility would be an issue.
Once an implant has properly osteo integrated it should not be mobile at all because it's
directly structurally and functionally connected to that bone so it's not going to move around.
On the opposite side of the coin fibrous integration means that we have a presence of fibrous tissue
between the implant and the bone so there's going to be some mobility and this is a failure
of osteo integration and therefore a failure of implant placement.
So along with this concept of placing the implant we have primary and secondary stability.
Secondary stability is when you first place the implant how well the screw threads lock
into the bone that is already there.
Secondary stability refers to osteo integration so after osteo integration occurs within a
few weeks new bone is formed that locks into that titanium alloy.
So in this helpful graph we start out here's the Y axis is stability from 0 to 100% and
the X axis is showing weeks 1, 2, 3, 4 and so on.
So we start out when we place the implant with very good primary stability we're just
screwing like a screw into a block of wood we're screwing in that implant into bone so
we start with really great primary stability then there's some resorption occurring and
we have a stability dip before the secondary stability takes effect.
So once we hit to around the four week mark then we start getting osteo integration so
new bone is forming healing and is locking into that titanium alloy.
So eventually that secondary stability with the new bone takes over from primary stability
and creates a successful outcome.
Now you can imagine if we don't have osteo integration we have fibrous integration that
blue line never happens and then we just get more and more mobility and that implant will
be spinning and rocking about and it would be a failure.
So we have to talk about bone quality because not all bone is created equal and so in this
list implant success rate goes from high to low.
So from the type one bone is pictured here on the left this is dense cortical bone it
provides the best primary stability but it does have some poor secondary stability due
to poor blood supply but that initial bone is so nice and dense and provides a great amount
of primary stability to work with.
This is found in the anterior mandible region.
And then we go to type two which is found in the posterior mandible.
Type three is found in the anterior maxilla and type four bone is found in the posterior
maxilla.
So type four is soft, medullary bone has very poor primary stability and so if you get very
poor primary stability right off the bat you're not going to have opportunity to create great
secondary stability even though you might have a good blood supply.
Now depending on what sources you look at some people might say well type two and type
three are actually the best for implant success because you get a good balance of primary
and secondary stability but I will say for the board exam know that type one is the best
type four is the worst.
In other words anterior mandible is the best place to place an implant posterior maxilla
is the worst place.
I've definitely seen these questions on the board exam absolutely so definitely know
type one through type four and what regions are associated with.
Oh here's another great slide I would put red text on this entire slide if I could because
this is probably the most valuable information in this whole video for the board exam where
to place an implant and what numbers to remember for staying away from certain structures and
being careful where to place them.
So when we place an implant we want to be at least or at minimum one millimeter away
from the buckle plate, the lingual plate, the inferior border of the mandible, the maxilla
berry sinus and the nasal cavity so when you place an implant let's say it's four millimeters
wide we need to make sure there's at least one millimeter of bone buckle to that and one
millimeter of bone lingual to that.
So in other words for a five millimeter implant which is a little bit wider than what it should
be that means with one millimeter buckle one millimeter lingual we would need a total buckle
lingual dimension a buckle lingual width of seven millimeters.
So they could ask that if you have an implant diameter of three millimeters how much buckle
lingual width would you need and you need to know that you need five millimeters and that's
coming just from knowing this number.
From adjacent natural teeth another great question you need at least 1.5 millimeters of space
between the implant and the adjacent tooth so this is another great question if you were
placing an implant in number 30 and you had 29 and 31 to either side let's say the implant
is three millimeters in diameter how much space mesiodistally would you need and so you'd
need to know well I need 1.5 on the distal side 1.5 on the mesial side the implant takes
up three millimeters so I would need six millimeters total things like that very simple
math problems that all you need to do is recall these numbers here.
We need to be two millimeters away from the inferior albial or nerve so we need at least
two millimeters of space right here that's called the safety zone we need three millimeters
of space between adjacent implants so for away from natural teeth this is one at least
one point five millimeters of distance between two implants this needs to be at least three
millimeters of distance might be a little bit close in this image and this one we definitely
have at least three millimeters of space between those two implants which is good although
you can see that it's right up against the inferior albial nerve which is not good we
need at least two millimeters of space there and lastly we should be at least five millimeters
away from the mental nerve or the mental frame and that's due to the anterior loop this nerve
loops around before it enters the mental frame and so it can be deceiving because you
might place the implant just anterior to the mental frame and but you still hit the nerve
because it loops around anteriorly so we have to be at least five millimeters away from
that structure so these are all really really important numbers to memorize absolutely I
can't stress enough how important this slide is to memorize alright now that we're we're
deep into the subject of surgery let's talk about one verse two stage surgeries so one
stage surgery involves placing the implant and a healing abutment in one visit so the
healing abutment or the cap is the healing cap is shown here and it sticks out of the
gums essentially like an earring and an ear is the best way I can describe it and so that
helps to sculpt and mold the soft tissues around the this implant healing abutment in
order to frame the restoration appropriately so when it's time for the patient to come
back you remove this temporary healing abutment and you put in the final abutment that soft
tissue has a really nice collar and provides a great emergence profile for the implant
the two stage surgery means that we place the implant with a cover screw which is a fin
little disc that you you screw into the implant it's another temporary measure but this time
we're covering it up with gums so the healing abutment sticks out of the gums this one is
completely covered with a primary closure and it's a two stage surgery because the next
time they come in we have to then open the gums and then place the abutment at the next
visit and this could be either the temporary healing abutment shown here or that final
abutment that we saw in the previous slides so why would we do two stage surgery because
most patients would want to just have one surgery and be done with it well two stage
can be beneficial for three main reasons I can think of if you have poor primary stability
so say we're working in the posterior maxilla and we want to keep all occlusion off of it
so we replace this cover screw and so we make sure that there are going to be no biting
forces on the implant while it's healing and secondary stability is taking over the second
reason would be if we need to place a graft so we'd want to close up the gums that the
bone heals properly the third reason is that if we have a medically compromised patient
so that immunocompromised or unstable diabetes from that contraindication slide so this technique
would allow primary closure of the over the implant site which poses a less infection
risk all right how about the impression so once healing is complete a final impression
is made so that the crown and the abutment are properly oriented so we use what's called
an impression coping which is used to transfer the location and angulation of the implant
to a master cast here is the impression coping so you can imagine the implant has been screwed
in maybe we did a one stage surgery we took out the healing abutment and now we're ready
to take our impression or maybe we did a cover screw first now we opened that area up and
we're ready to take an impression so the coping attaches into the implant in the mouth and
allows you to record the angulation of the implant which without a set of 2D x-rays or
a 3D x-ray we can't see the implant angulation once it's screwed in because well as you can
see here it's surrounded by gums and bones so we can't see anything so we screw in this
impression coping which allows us to see and which allows us to imagine where that implant
is without any second guessing so this slide is totally beyond the scope of the board exam
but I just wanted to include this information number one because I'm so excited about it
but number two because I know a lot of you are really curious about implants so the open
tray impression is when you physically drill a hole in the plastic impression tray so that
you can once the impression is seated you can access the coping once the material sets
so there's a hole in the impression tray we might put a little piece of cotton in this
little tiny screw hole here so that we can access it without plugging in the impression
material that polyvinyl siloxane getting set into that screw hole so we can go back and
later once the material sets unscrew this coping from the implant and then there's
a record of where that impression coping was so you can later seat it in that spot.
The closed tray impression is when you take the impression like normal and then you remove
the impression and then there's a little space in the impression material where that impression
coping was so then you later would unscrew that impression coping and then seat it in
the spot where it was on the impression so each technique has pros and cons and utilizes
a different looking impression coping this is an open tray impression coping so once you
have that impression you put a little pink stuff around the coping to block it out and
represent the gingiva called the gingival melage then you screw this thing in which
is called the analog into the coping you pour it up like any old impression and you get
a master cast where the analog will essentially be in the exact same position embedded in
that stone of the cast as the implant is in the mouth so the analog provides your precise
replication of the implant positioned in the mouth so that's a very very cursory overlook
at implant impressions just to introduce some of these concepts and terms.
So socket preservation is something that we see in the oral surgery world and this is
to maintain the height and width of the alveolar ridge after a tooth extraction.
So the most important part about socket preservation is to have an atramatic extraction so we're
shooting for potentially a simple extraction or a non-surgical extraction we're not breaking
off the buckle plate of the extracted tooth we're limiting any sort of trauma to the area
and then we do a lot of the same things we do following an extraction we irrigate that
extraction site very thoroughly we remove granulation tissue with the curette but then
we also place bone graft material and we like to cover that with a resorbable collagen membrane
if you remember from the periodontic series that's some of the things that we talked about
with a guided tissue regeneration is a similar process we want to regenerate the bone in that
area to help fill in that socket but also to limit any bone loss in a buckle lingual
or occlusal direction primary closure with this procedure is actually unnecessary.
Biologic width this is something we I have a entire video just dedicated to the feral
effect in biologic width but here it's a little bit different we're talking about the implant
being placed into bone this surface that's contacting bone is roughened to help with osteo
integration the smooth surface is contacting the soft tissue here the soft tissue collar
and so the gingival fibers orient next to that implant in a parallel direction so it's
parallel with the implant cuff and that's the area notated with the A here and so gingival
fibers orient next to the implant parallel with the cuff and this could be asked on the
board exam how the gingival fibers are oriented next to an implant the other important thing
to note here is that the tooth has a periodontal ligament an implant does not have a periodontal
ligament because it's directly contacting the alveolar bone so without periodontal ligament
there's technically no peridontium so the implant is unique in that matter as well
the surgical stent I also mentioned this earlier in the video this is referring to guided surgery
so we have a stent made we place in the patient's mouth and this metal sleeve helps to guide
the implant drill as we're drilling the hole and delivering the implant so the surgical
stent can provide LAD for location, angulation and depth of placement to make sure any and
all implants being placed are aligned properly with the surgical stent so it can help in that
matter and finally we're going to talk about implant success and implant failure and the
features that go along with each of those so the four main characteristics of implant
success are that it's immobile and we talked about the fibrous integration having that fibrous
layer in between the implant and bone and how that's not desirable because we want that
bone to be fully osteo integrated and immobile there should be no peri implant radio lucency
there should be or there will be rather some peri implant bone loss and particularly there's
some initial bone loss that's to be expected but virtually no bone loss afterwards so less
than 0.2 millimeters per year after the first year and then absence of symptoms namely pain
infection, parastasia, those sorts of things so we should have no movement, no radio lucency,
virtually no bone loss and no symptoms so therefore mobility, pain, radio lucency and peri implant
bone loss would be all signs of implant failure, gram negative, anaerobic rods and filaments
are often associated with implant failure, peri implant, tightus, those sorts of things
and one more, I'm sorry, one more important number for the board exam, 47 degrees Celsius
for one minute or 40 degrees Celsius for seven minutes is enough to compromise osteo integration
so again, this goes back to one of those first slides I had to reduce the amount of heat generated
with a sharp drill, copious irrigation and sequentially enlarging the osteotomy is so
important because we don't want to compromise osteo integration before even the implant is
placed alright so that's it for this very long video, thank you so much for watching everyone
I really hope you enjoyed learning a little bit about the fascinating world of dental
implants if you're interested in supporting the channel please check out my patreon
page a huge thank you to michael raja and all of my patrons for their support you can
unlock extras like access to these video slides to take notes on and additional practice questions
for the board exam so go check that out the link will be in the description below thanks
Thanks again for watching, I'll see you all in the next video.